se balader dans la cité des ducs en
foulant ses pavés aux en foulant son
béton les deux possibilités dont de
toute évidence pas le même cachet alors
forcément la bétonisation d'une partie
du centre ville reste encore un mystère
pour certains riverains pour moi des
gens c'est d'ehpad et le fait qu'on
mette un revêtement comme ça voilà moi
je sais pas j'ai pas trop pour surtout
que je souvent en vélo ça glisse pas mal
hiver quand il fait les grosses chaleurs
gagnent réverbération au niveau du
soleil surtout la chaleur en fin de
journée encore très présente
la ville de dijon at elle fait les bons
choix en terme d'urbanisme
c'est en tout cas la question que
soulève l'opposition municipale du
centre et de la droite
des critiques auxquelles l'adjointe au
maire chargé de ces questions a accepté
de répondre dans un communiqué
l'opposition évoque d'abord une dalle de
béton sans recherche sans cacher et sans
âme soit koala fils répond ça fait un
rendu assez joli justement ce contraste
entre ses façades
vous avez remarqué que nous avons des
très belles façades et très beaux hôtels
particuliers
la pierre de bourgogne enquête façade et
béton bouchardés ça fait un très beau
rendu toujours selon l'opposition ce
choix laisse tout un quartier sans ombre
sur une surface réverbérante est
cuisante
nous n'allons pas mettre des arbres dans
toute la ville vous pensez bien que
c'est pas possible
mais nous allons en maître vous en avez
place jean macé vous en avez place darcy
nous en aurons place de la sainte
chapelle
bien sûr tout ça et privés enfin les
matériaux utilisés serez peu qualitatifs
et peu représentatif de la richesse
patrimoniale du quartier vous savez j'ai
travaillé avec l'architecte des
bâtiments de france c'est pas nous qui
décidons comme ça de faire tout et
n'importe quoi tout est travaillé et
étudié regardé et je pense que là on
respecte tout à fait le patrimoine un
patrimoine dont fait partie le centre
historique de dijon
c'est l'un des 44 site français inscrit
à l'unesco